uh another comment from Stevens that
everyone should hit the vice comment
thread asking for the unedited version
oh yeah please yeah do it they'd never
show that no they would never do it then
uh Pat Steadman said see how Tate was
edited how by Pierce Morgan years ago
how roosh was edited after appearing on
Dr Oz should she know better than to go
on Vice
yeah I just I just was gonna do it
anyway I was like you can't yeah I still
felt like message in my prayer I still
felt like I came out more sane than
those crazies even let me ask you
however much they edited it cameras off
did you did you how did you did you get
along with those wigs they looked pissed
and actually oh wait Eli tweeted did you
see it did you see what I tweeted back
he liked tweeted I don't know if you
have that in the copy I saw it no I
didn't see the feedback but this is what
Eli this is a I keep saying it because
I'm going to it's a biological man trans
woman says ready to get heated I joined
at Vice news for a debate panel on
feminism it's not helpful to platform
fascists like Vice did this talking
about you about a fashion it's a harsh
accusation but I figured the least I
could do is prevent the anti-feminism
spreading even more disinformation
there's that word they love oh somebody
they disagree with that hurt their
feelings disinformation what did you
Tweet back I didn't say oh I tweeted
aren't you a predator or am I tripping
no no I'm gonna be honest he could be he
could I'm just saying if you're gonna
call me a fascist yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna point out that so how was it when
the cameras weren't rolling with Eli and
crew well before they separated the
conservatives and the lips so like they
put us in different rooms and it was
very like they were kind of they had
people in there and they're like don't
talk about polit like don't talk about
the panel stuff which I understand I do
that too sometimes yeah before shows
I'll be like don't talk about the topic
ah because you want to get it on camera
so I I respect that I understand that
um then we do the panel which is super
long oh my gosh I was so hot too you
know how like sometimes it gets like hot
in these it's hot in here yeah yeah UK
there's no AC yeah that's why you see
people sweating on the show sometimes
they just don't have it there I don't
know
but but they um basically I forgot where
I was going oh then after I was so
awkward because it was like we both went
in our groups and we're just talking
[ __ ] about the others at like lunch or
whatever but no I did not get along with
them especially a lady in the wheelchair
and Eli is trying to tell me oh let me
use my body to test if biological males
can compete with women sure let me let
me let me be the test dummy oh my God
these people are crazy yeah the context
for that was that you were talking about
how it wasn't fair for biological men to
be competing with women and you used
your own example you said I'm an athlete
this wouldn't be fair and they they
somehow found that I still play I play
Semi-Pro right now I'm still playing and
I was I almost went pro last year I like
took volleyball to basically the highest
level that I could have and I'm gonna
tell you dudes would kill us yeah it
would kill us I can't compete with
doodoo six seven six five I can't do
[ __ ] isn't it crazy that to say that is
controversial though it shouldn't be
it's crazy I just don't want to play
with dudes call me crazy yeah and they
brought up the bathrooms all the oh
we're gonna get it I don't want them in
the bathrooms either I'll say that I'll
say it now yeah get get them out get him
out how big it of you I'm sorry I don't
I don't need that I don't need that
Delhi we got more yeah okay you guys you
got a question from the house of pain he
says after all the formality formalities
what is the most important question
should men ask on the first date
for both of you guys are you feminist
what do you think if they say yes you
just it's nice no I want to split the
bills here
that's a good one I don't know what a
man should ask do you want kids is a
good one too because I would ask her a
little bit about her family like I would
get to know the person and the value
system that built that woman you know
let her talk if she's like oh I don't
talk to my family oh this and always
more than what you ask is what you pay
attention to I find that women who bring
up other relationships you'll get a take
them out to a place where there's other
guys see if they look around the room if
they're looking for attention that's
good advice that's good advice yeah
that's what I would do see how they
behave because then you'll learn a lot
about somebody by the way they you know
their attention seeking from other men
on the date would you be surprised you
see some crazy
okay Delhi yeah we have one more
question this one's for Pearl Pearl your
content is so important for Our
Generation I wanted to ask why Brown men
are so low on The Dating hierarchy what
can we do
Brown men
um
I don't know if I could answer is that
true I don't know on the date I don't
even know if I buy the premise I thought
I think it's like he's talking about
like Indian like I'm pretty sure guys in
India like in it's like Eastern Asia I
have the lowest swipe right on a dating
apps oh okay
um
I mean I think it's like basically the
only thing you can do is with the like
red pill manosphere teaches is money
muscles game frame like I can't think of
anything else to add how much do you
like I don't know how you identify
yourself in this like manosphere red
like how would you identify yourself in
this space Oh my gosh I was thinking
about this the other day like I wouldn't
consider myself like I always try to
give credit where a lot of like the
ideas came from and like you know
there's people I really respect in the
space like roller like I think I think
he's a genius honestly
um I would say I'm more of like a
cultural commentator with also about
relationships that's more what I would
identify as what do you think is
important about the messages I've had
Rollo on here A bunch of times and what
I like about him is that he really digs
deep into the content so he's not just
spewing talking points this is a guy
who's like done his research has his
stats but what do you think in terms of
the messaging that they have for men
what do you think that it's that's good
about that is there anything you think
is bad about it
in terms of what they're saying to guys
the self-improvement stuff is good like
I think always like that's that's like
what they all say they're all about self
I think minus Rolex I would say Rolo
does more like the research and
development you know as he says
um I would say all the self-improvement
stuff I think is great
see I see what's interesting to me is
the people who are bothered by the Rolos
and the people who like watch your
channel and get and go insane I mean I'm
sure there's women at home that watch
your channel they just like lose their
minds over it and I'm curious to ask you
like what do you think about what kinds
of men are bothered by content in the
manuscript like what do you think their
life looks like oh my gosh I have a guy
that just came to mind I had a guy I'm
not gonna say the name okay this guy
camel
I know it's coming and and he was on our
show please don't look at him oh please
don't
foreign
keep going I don't care and he he was um
on one of my early early shows he's like
super early on like first I don't know
five ten episodes
and he was messaging me when all that
stuff was talking about like submission
and like Ali's Tick Tock or whatever was
going viral and he was telling me like
he was like like what you want to be
owned by a guy and I just kept thinking
beta I'm like you've never had a girl
listen to you huh yeah they seem weak
they seem you know sometimes very lazy
because it takes a lot I mean these guys
are so tough on guys like they're really
tough it's like get your [ __ ] together
get in the gym like you're responsible
for yourself you need to like earn the
money you and you gotta be able to
protect your girl you got to know your
self-defense it's like if you're sitting
at home and you're lazy playing the
video games I mean you're gonna be
wrecked you're gonna you're just you
know if you don't want to be motivated
and you're comfortable in your laziness
these guys are gonna rub you wrong yeah
but what about the women the women who
are triggered by you who are those women
whales sorry I mean beautiful majestic
creatures that live in the city so
people who struggle with obesity but who
else who else
um
I'd say girls that are like very
promiscuous get triggered when I talk
about like body count
um I would say that
thumb and oh my gosh feminists hate me
they look at me did you see that panel
they hated me they did they did I'm like
I have been perfectly polite you see
when she called me pretty I'm like thank
you
she didn't even mean to she's trying to
insult me as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible